noch nie ist ein asteroid dabei
beobachtet worden wie er so nah an der
erde vorbei geschafft ist fast wäre er
sogar auf der erde nieder gegangen und
die gefahr ist hoch dass schon bald ein
größerer ast ohrid auf der erde
einschlägt den asteroiden sind gar nicht
so selten wie manche leute glauben in
kosmischen maßstäben befinden wir uns
quasi in einem regelrechten asteroiden
bonbon in den letzten jahren wurden
sogar zwei asteroiden entdeckt kurz
danach auf der erde niedergehen klicks
um science in future.de bis dreimal pro
woche spannende science videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
so verpasst ihr nichts los gehen
herzlich willkommen auch das ist ein
zukunftsszenario wie ich es ähnlich bei
vielen anderen phänomen beschreiben in
meinem neuen buch verkauft sowie den
weltraum der link ist hier unter be oder
unten in der video beschreibung denn
viele gefahren chancen und möglichkeiten
werden mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit
realität und zwar schon bald in der
nahen zukunft eine pandemie okay die ist
jetzt schon realität geworden quanten
computing und künstliche intelligenz der
flug zum mars der kontakt mit alien
künstliches fleisch und mit ihm das ende
der tierzucht und so weiter und so fort
und der einschlag eines größeren der
wird auch schon bald passieren und jetzt
ist es ganz knapp nicht passiert so
knapp wie noch nie zumindest beobachtet
dabei gibt es ein großes missverständnis
asteroiden sind keine seltenheit die
erde befindet sich in kosmischen
maßstäben in einem asteroiden regen
ständig schwirren uns die brocken
tatsächlich um die ohren
dabei war der einschlag oder beinahe ein
schlag ins schilder binz der bisher
beste beobachtungszeit ein und
errichtete eine menge schäden an dabei
war dieser hast du mit gerade einmal 20
meter groß dennoch wurden bei der
druckwelle rund 1500 menschen verletzt
und zahlreiche gebäude beschädigt solche
kleineren felsen können also beim
einschlag ausglich gewaltige schäden
anrichten und achtung die gefährdung
steigt mit der größe exponentiell weil
das volumen der kugel sogar nicht nur
zum quadrat sondern eben sogar hoch 3
steigt es geht ja um drei dimensionen
das volumen einer kugel wird mit vier
drittel martina
hoch drei berechnet wer lust hat kann
das ja mal für verschiedenen radien
brechen 55 meter zum beispiel also wie
viel mal größer ist das volumen wenn der
radius zehnmal größer ist da kommen
schon ziemlich beeindruckende zahlen und
vor allem eine sehr beeindruckende
steigerung zustande und je kleiner ein
objekt ist desto größer ist der brems
und erhitzung effekt unsere atmosphäre
kleinere meteore schaffen das meistens
nicht macht bis zum erdboden und auch
der jetzt so knapp an der erde
vorbeigeflogen brocken 20 20 vt4 hätte
es wahrscheinlich nicht zum erdboden
geschafft trotzdem war seine distanz nur
absolut minimal
asteroiden sind ja ein überbleibsel von
der entstehung unseres sonnensystems die
meisten von ihnen ziehen
glücklicherweise weit entfernt von der
erde ihre runden um die sonne zwischen
den planeten mars und jupiter im
asteroidengürtel anderer eben aber dann
doch nicht die erde ist ständig bedroht
von kollisionen mit erdmann hast du
jeden viele objekte sind klein und
vergnügen in der atmosphäre ohne dass
wir es bemerken dass ein himmelskörper
die atmosphäre eindringt und explodiert
oder einschlägt kommt allerdings viel
viel öfter vor als wir denken wie oft
das in den letzten jahren pro jahr
passiert ist wurde vor einigen jahren
untersucht wir hatten darüber berichtet
26 asteroiden sind im laufe von 13
jahren auf der erde eingeschlagen
forschende hatten die idee beim
weltweiten atomteststopp überwachungs
netzwerk nachzufragen ob es andere
größere explosion auf der erde gab und
es waren 26 lediglich ein einschlag
wurden dabei vorher gesehen alle anderen
kamen im wahrsten sinne des wortes aus
heiterem himmel genauso wie der jetzt
entdeckte er nächste beobachtete astori
dieses jahr schlagen also zwei
asteroiden hier auf der erde ein bisher
hatten wir bei diesen anschlägen großes
glück denn die gesteinsbrocken stuben in
mehr wüsten oder sonstigen unbewohnten
gebieten ein und verdampften bereits in
der atmosphäre das jetzt dem thema mehr
aufmerksamkeit gewidmet wird ist ein
mega wichtiger schritt um die menschheit
vor einer katastrophe zu schützen eine
wahnsinnig wichtige zivilisations
leistung ohne die wir auf dauer nicht
überleben würden wir haben ja über die
bänder asteroiden mission berichtet wo
jetzt ein programm startet um die bahn
dieses
zudem so abzulenken dass er nicht auf
der erde einschlägt und das wäre bei
benny mit seinen 500 metern durchmesser
und 87 millionen tonnen gewicht eine
absolute katastrophe die sonde osiris
rex hat den hast du ihn jetzt gerade
detailliert gescannt und kurz auf bd
aufgesetzt und sogar proben entnommen
die damen anfang nächsten jahres zurück
zur erde geflogen werden und dann hier
in laboren untersucht werden können aber
schon jetzt wissen wir viel mehr über
die zusammensetzung des asteroiden als
die raumsonde nämlich bei benno ankamen
entdeckte sie ein extrem seltsames
phänomen immer wieder hoben kleine
gesteinsbrocken vom asteroiden ab sie
umkreisten ihn und fielen dann wieder
auf ihn zurück das war als wenn jemand
auf der oberfläche diesem moment eigens
hoch warf damit wir ihre bahn verfolgen
konnten unsere kollegen konnten dann aus
ihrem flug bahn auf das schwerefeld von
bennett schließen so daniel scheeres von
der university of colorado in boulder
dieser umstand waffe die vorstand ein
riesen glück denn jetzt wissen sie viel
besser als bisher wie der story
zusammengesetzt ist er ist nämlich wie
ein makro in der mitte und am äquator
ist es weich und er besteht aus geröll
während der oben und unten härtere
kappen besitzt obwohl vielleicht ist es
sogar mehr als weich im zentrum oder
weniger je nachdem wie man es sieht es
scheint als wenn es im zentrum einen
wohnraum gibt in dem mehrere football
felder hinein passen würden so schwer es
im laufe der zeit so die vermutung der
vorstellung hat sich wohl das herz von
gestein nach außen verteilt und das
geröll blieb im inneren dadurch wird das
solid installiert was dazu führen könnte
dass wenn er irgendwann auseinander
fliegt allerdings wird das nicht vor
einer möglichen kollision mit der erde
passieren die ist nämlich nicht
unwahrscheinlich wenn du s bahn haben
wir bis ins jahr 2100 35 vorausberechnet
dann würde er sich der erde bis auf
ungefähr 280 1000 kilometer annähernd
danach ist ein weiterer kurs unsicher da
er davon abhängt wie nahe er der erde
wirklich kommt und wie stark sie seine
bahn verändert unseren analysen zufolge
könnte er beim nächsten mal im jahr 2000
an
67 mit einer wahrscheinlichkeit von 1 zu
2700 auf der erde einschlagen
eine studie aus 2009 berechnete eine
serie von möglichen zusammenstößen mit
der erde zwischen 2169 und 2199 doch die
genaue wahrscheinlichkeit für eine
kollision
die war bisher nicht wirklich zu
beziffern denn die physikalischen
eigenschaften des asteroiden waren noch
weitestgehend unbekannt das hat sich
jetzt geändert und es kann genauer
gerechnet werden dabei ist er nur einer
von 870 objekten die in den nächsten 100
jahren auf kollisionskurs mit der erde
sind das hat die europäische
raumfahrtagentur esa berechnet und das
sind nur die objekte von denen wir
wissen
dazu stefan hula mac vom deutschen
zentrum für luft und raumfahrt in einem
interview mit golem.de die frage ist
überhaupt nicht ob wir wieder getroffen
werden die frage ist wann wir wieder
getroffen werden doch das aufspüren und
untersuchen wenn es denn gelingt wie bei
bengel ist nur ein erster entscheidender
schritt in einem zweiten schritt muss es
auch darum geht aktiv zu werden und
strategien zur planetaren verteidigung
einsetzen zu können
fachleute sind der ansicht dass barca
iden ab einer größe von 50 metern über
eine ablenkung nachgedacht werden muss
und genau dabei könnte die erste
planetare verteidigungs mission
überhaupt helfen die daten mission noch
mal zur erinnerung da steht dabei für
double sj redirection test wir haben
schon darüber berichtet dieser soll
einschlagen und zwar auf einem erdmann
doppel hast du ihnen 6 5 803 aufgespürt
wurde dieser vor 24 jahren aus der 96
und astronomie teams stecken ziemlich
schnell dass es sich bei diesem objekt
um einen doppel körper handelt deswegen
sein name didi muss denn das ist die
bezeichnung die griechische bezeichnung
für zwillinge der größere brocken von
beiden hat einen durchmesser von 780
metern
der kleinere einen durchmesser von etwa
160 metern dieser kleinere mond wird
manchmal auch als diddy moon oder die
more fonds bezeichnet bisher wissen wir
dass die mossos den größeren körper in
einer entfernung von etwa 1,1 kilometern
umkreist und für eine umrundung rund
11,9 stunden benötigt um das direkt
einmal klarzustellen das zielobjekt ist
aktuell keine bedrohung für unsere erde
das nasa manöver dient lediglich dazu
uns für den ernstfall vorzubereiten
im experiment im fokus der kleinere der
beiden brocken denn hier möchte die nasa
ihre raum sondern dateien schlagen
lassen und so seine band verändern
konkret sieht der platz so aus mit einer
geschwindigkeit von 23.000 kilometern
pro stunde soldat auf die mauer fonds
treffen
so soll ein impuls auf den himmelskörper
übertragen werden so dass nicht nur
seine geschwindigkeit sondern auch seine
bahn leicht verändert wird durch den
aufprall wird material von der
oberfläche auf geschleudert dadurch soll
es einen zusätzlichen impuls geben
wodurch dieser effekt verstärkt wird
bisherigen berechnungen zufolge könnte
es zu einer veränderung der bahn
geschwindigkeit von etwa 0,4 mm pro
sekunde geben klingt zunächst einmal
nach einer minimalen veränderung in drei
sekunden sind das aber 1,2 millimeter
wieder zusammenkommen in zehn 1,2
zentimeter in einer minute 72 zentimeter
in 10 72 zentimeter in einer stunde 400
meter in einem tag 100 metern so weiter
also locker messbar fachleuten zufolge
wäre eine solche neuausrichtung groß
genug um sie mit teleskopen von der erde
aus zu messen
dieses manöver würde uns damit endlich
zeigen ob wir mit solch einer mission
tatsächlich auch einen asteroiden der
sich auf kollisionskurs mit der erde
befindet erfolgreich umlenken könnten
denn fest steht schon eine kleine
flugbahn änderung eines asteroiden
könnte das fortbestehen der erde
sicherstellen und in diesem fall wären
es sogar mehrere kilometer pro jahr bahn
veränderungen und je nach flug bahn wird
dieser abstand ja dann bis zur erde
vervielfacht für die fachleute ist
dieses experiment ganz besonders
spannend und spektakulär denn es handelt
sich um den ersten himmelskörper dessen
physikalische und orbitale eigenschaften
von menschenhand verändert werden die
zur mission gehörige lehrer sondern wird
von dem satellitenbauer ohb systems ag
in bremen gebaut und bekommt dafür von
der esa etwa 130 millionen euro her
sondern im oktober 2004 und 20 staaten
und weitere zwei jahre später also 2026
das ziel die die muss erreichen
mit hilfe von era soll dann genauer
untersucht werden welche effekte der
aufprall auf die mossos hat die sonde
ist nach angaben der esa etwa so groß
wie ein schreibtisch der offizielle plan
sieht vor dass die sonne 60
lang daten sammeln sollen es wird
nämlich auch höchste zeit denn fachleute
waren immer wieder vor der bedrohung aus
dem all und plädieren für eine weltweite
zusammenarbeit für den aufbau eines
koordinierten frühwarnsystems maßgeblich
an der entwicklung in der forschung
dieser themen beteiligt sie nasa behörde
namens planetary die fans team noch im
sommer 2018 hatte die nasa ein
ausführliches strategiepapier zu
asteroiden abwehr vor wenig demnach
müssen dringend möglichkeiten entwickelt
werden mit denen die flugbahn von
gesteinsbrocken beeinflusst werden
können wichtig sind vor allem zwei
sachen erstens potenziell gefährliche
asteroiden müssen früh genug aufgespürt
werden
doch da liegt die erste große
herausforderungen das klappt noch lange
immer nicht so führt beispielsweise der
erst 2019 okay im juli des vergangenen
jahres 2019 unbemerkt an der erde vorbei
fachleute zufolge war er fast aus dem
nichts gekommen und dennoch ist er in
einer distanz von 72.000 190 kilometern
an der erde vorbei gerauscht und das mit
einem durchmesser von 90 metern rund
einen kilometer groß dagegen bis der
weltraum brocken 2020 q6 diesen hatte
ein brasilianischer hobby-astronom erst
anfang september 2020 entdeckt 90
prozent der erdnahe objekte mit solch
einer größe gelten eigentlich als
bekannt doch die meisten hast du ihn
beobachtungs missionen sind auf der
nordhalbkugel stationiert deswegen war
2020 q6 der sich von der südlichen
hemisphäre genähert hatte zunächst
unentdeckt geblieben am 10 september
hatte er dann die erde in einem abstand
von 40 millionen kilometer passiert also
entwarnung mehr als die hundertfache
distanz von der erde zum mond dennoch
schrieb die planetary society danach
dass diese späte entdeckung deutlich
mache dass mehr für den schutz unseres
planeten getan werden muss und das
objekt 20 20 vt4 hat jetzt noch mal
demonstriert wie real diese gefahr ist
denn dieser street flug nicht nur näher
als der mond an uns vorbei also näher
als rund 400.000 kilometer näher als die
geostationären satelliten mit einer
entfernung von 36.000 kilometern mehr
als die starling satelliten von spacex
dieser hasso ihn
unter flog sogar die raumstation iss der
abstand betrug noch lächerliche 380
kilometer
das ist absolut nichts und es zeigt
deutlich dass asteroiden anschläge viel
viel wahrscheinlicher sind als viele
glauben in den letzten jahren wurden
sogar zwei
2008 tc3 und 2014 a vor dem einschlag
auf der erde beobachtet sie hatten
jeweils nur einem durchmesser von zwei
bis drei metern und sind in unbewohnten
gebiet nieder gegangen also absolut
entfernung aber es ist nur eine frage
der zeit wann ein großer brocken
tatsächlich auf der erde einschlägt und
mehr zukunftsszenarien verheißungsvolle
und bedrohliche gibt es in meinem buch
per aufzug in den weltraum der link ist
hier einfach draufklicken und ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran